Speaker 1: I did a story yesterday where I
talked about the differences between Republicans
and Democrats, especially related to holding
our own accountable, and in that video I discussed
Andrew Cuomo and that there was an unavoidable
march toward impeachment that wasn't going
to be able to be avoided, unavoidable.
He couldn't avoid it.
That's how it works.
That's how language works.
Dumb guy.
So this morning, press conference was held
just about nine my time here in Southern California
and.
Andrew Cuomo, I almost called him Chris again,
dumb guy.
Andrew Cuomo resigned or he gave his two weeks
notice.
And there are a few moments in his press conference,
in his announcement video, his live stream
that I want to address because, yes, he's
doing the right thing.
He's leaving.
He is doing it to save himself the shame of
being the only governor of the state of New
York to ever be impeached and removed from
office.
But he is doing it in a very recalcitrant
way, it's aggressive, it is trying to give
deference to the 11 women who have accused
him of misconduct while also saying, I didn't
know the rules have changed.
I'm an affectionate guy.
And I don't believe that is acceptable, it
certainly in a post me era.
But it's not acceptable for a leader, for
a politician, for someone who is in charge
of policy decisions, especially related to
sexual assault and sexual misconduct, and
he is a man who should be intelligent enough
to understand consent.
You don't get to just kiss people without
them saying it's OK to touch me.
It's OK to put your body on mine.
Let's cut to this first clip where he's talking
about this thing that he just didn't know.
Speaker 3: I take full responsibility for
my actions.
I have been too familiar with people.
My sense of humor can be insensitive and off-putting.
I do hug and kiss people casually, women and
men.
I have done it all my life.
It's who I've been since I can remember.
In my mind, I've never crossed the line with
anyone, but I didn't realize the extent to
which the line has been redrawn.
There are generational and cultural shifts
that I just didn't fully appreciate.
Speaker 1: So Andrew Cuomo would take on the
old grandpa approach to his defense.
Here I am an old man and I didn't know that
the rules have changed.
Colored ladies, honey and sweetie, kissing
him on the cheeks.
This doesn't pass the smell test for me anyway,
I think in many ways Andrew Cuomo has been
a standout governor.
I think he got a little too much praise for
his covid response, especially in the wake
of scandal where they lied about nursing home
deaths as as a mechanism to stave off an investigation.
That's that's the excuse they gave.
That's not what I'm saying.
They said that.
But this is not an acceptable excuse that
guess a lot of people hug a lot of people.
That's just me.
Listen, I'm an affectionate guy, I'm a hugger,
I'm a toucher.
But it is common sense that you don't impose
yourself upon someone else before getting
consent, being told it's OK.
It just that's the way it is, and especially
if you're the governor of the state of New
York, knowing the immense power and influence
and authority that you have in that position,
you have to walk a little bit more carefully.
Because of that power, the aura of authority
around you, you're not Joe who works down
at the Jiffy Lube, who gets a little fresh
with the client and doesn't know it because
he's Joe who works down at the Jiffy Lube.
You're the governor of the state of New York.
Next up is again, while he apologizes and
says, oh, I just didn't know he's couching
he's hedging his his apology and his admitting
to what he did with this is a political witch
hunt.
It all smacks very much to me like a Trump
excuse.
Speaker 3: Now, you know me.
I'm a New Yorker, born and bred.
I am a fighter.
And my instinct is to fight through this controversy
because I truly believe it is politically
motivated.
I believe it is unfair and it is untruthful.
And I believe it it demonizes behavior that
is unsustainable for society.
If I could communicate the facts through the
frenzy, New Yorkers would understand, I believe
that when I took my oath as governor, then
it changed.
I became a fighter, but I became a fighter
for you.
And it is your best interest that I must serve.
Speaker 1: Those are all words that have crossed
the lips of Donald Trump many times.
How unfair it is that it's politically motivated,
which is just another way to say it's a witch
hunt.
That that that it's untruthful, these are
lies.
If they are lies, Governor Cuomo, then why
indeed, sir, are you resigning?
If this is baseless, why are you resigning?
You can't have it both ways that it's a political
witch hunt, but then also admit that a lot
of women were offended.
That they were uncomfortable, they were made
uncomfortable by you and your advances.
Not to mention the fact that some of these
accusations rise to the level of criminal
prosecution.
Reaching under women's blouses and touching
their breasts.
Running your finger along the belly button
over to the side of the hip where the weapon
is carried on your female.
Protective duty state trooper.
This isn't just I didn't know I'm a huggy
guy, no.
And then finally.
The moment where he says he's going to resign
Speaker 3: and I think that given the circumstances,
the best way I can help now is if I step aside
and let the government get back to governing.
And therefore, that's what I would do because
I work for you and doing the right thing is
doing the right thing for you, because as
we say, it's not about me, it's about way.
Speaker 1: And in the wake of this, the female
lieutenant governor of the state of New York
will be sworn in in about two weeks or so
to be the first female governor of the state
of New York.
I find myself saying this a lot, but it's
twenty, twenty one.
We are on the heels of twenty twenty two.
And this is the first female governor in the
history of the state of New York.
We can do better than that, we can absolutely
do better than that.
And listen, I know I ruffle a lot of feathers
over on my own channel when I when I wield
criticisms of Democrats, when I have things
to say that are critical of Joe Biden or Nancy
Pelosi or in this case, Andrew Cuomo, reasonable,
reasonable people can disagree.
Agreeably and reasonably, and this might be
one of those cases,